-Oh, come on now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel the love.
Give it right back to you.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
This is "The Tonight Show."
Well, a lot of people
are talking about this.
Last night,
the Kansas City Chiefs
played the Minnesota Vikings
and Taylor Swift
was not in attendance.
[ Audience oohs ]
That's how crazy things
have gotten.
Now it's news when Taylor
doesn't show up, you know?
That's right. Thousands of fans
wanted to see
Taylor but couldn't.
Then Ticketmaster was like,
"Don't look at us.
We had nothing to do with this.
We had nothing."
Taylor not being there
was kind of a letdown.
When Patrick Mahomes
threw the ball to Travis Kelce,
he just let it fall.
He was like, "What's the point?
I mean, what -- why
are we doing this?"
Speaking of football,
on Saturday,
Iowa State played TCU,
and I noticed that
Iowa State's uniform combination
made it look like
some of their players were --
Well, just look at this photo.
Zoom in.
[ Laughter ]
For a second,
I thought Iowa State
signed a deal with Pampers,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, if Taylor Swift isn't
dating one of your players,
you got to do something
to get attention.
You know what I'm saying?
Let's get to some news.
Over the weekend,
at a rally in Iowa,
former president Trump
bragged that he could beat
President Biden in a fight.
[ Laughter ]
It would be the fight
of the century,
mostly because
both guys are a century.
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news today.
Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
launched his bid for president
as an independent.
Let's see how
the big announcement went.
-I need my speech.
[ Laughter ]
I can't read anything.
-You can't read anything.
-What about the screen
up in front?
[ Crowd chanting ]
-Yeah.
It's upside down.
[ Laughter ]
-Americans are like, "Okay,
is there
a fourth party candidate?
I mean, come on."
Things got better
once he started his speech
and then his pants fell down.
Oh, yeah,
he was wearing Pampers.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys hear about this?
I read that Amazon's Alexa
has been telling people
the 2020 election was stolen.
It's not good.
Now, when you ask Alexa,
"What's the weather?"
She says, "I don't know.
Why don't you ask Big Pharma?"
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
This week, Walgreens pharmacy
workers across the country
are planning walkouts
over their working conditions.
Yep, hundreds of Walgreens
pharmacies will be closed,
and in a month or two, people
will notice something's up.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears, have you guys
heard about
this massive Kia
and Hyundai recall?
It's not good.
Take a look at this.
-If you drive
a Kia or a Hyundai,
you'll want to hear this.
The government is issuing
a massive recall
for over 3 million vehicles
and says you should park
outside when you can.
That's because the affected cars
are at risk of catching fire
at any moment.
-What?!
Oh, man. I drive a Kia.
-Oh, geez. I'm sorry, Tariq.
-It's okay.
I'm glad I found out about it
before it was too late.
Then besides, I still have
my trusty Volkswagen.
-Oh.
-"Oh" what?
-Roll the clip.
-An important recall alert
this morning
for Volkswagen owners
as the automaker sounds the
alarm on nearly 50,000 vehicles.
-What?!
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Tariq.
-I mean,
I guess I could bicycle.
-Yeah.
-I just bought a bike
with the Shimano bonded 11-speed
Hollowtech road cranksets.
-A recall alert you
to know about this morning
if you bicycle.
Shimano is recalling
nearly 700,000
bonded 11-speed
Hollowtech road cranksets.
-Oh, come on!
-There's got to be something
that you can do.
-No, no, no. I'm done.
I'm just going to stay home
where it's safe
and eat snacks all day.
-Oh, yeah. What kind of snacks
do you like?
-Well, I have a sweet tooth,
So I'm talking about,
you know,
slices of that chocolate
"explosion" cake
that are sold at Walmart.
-We have a recall alert for
those of you
who have a sweet tooth.
-Yeah, we're talking
about slices of chocolate
"explosion" cake
that was sold at Walmart.
-Fine.
I'll eat something else then.
I have, you know,
70 million units of 2-ounce
to 3-ounce rolling liquid
county -- can-- candies.
-Candy Dynamics is recalling
70 million units of its 2-ounce
to 3-ounce rolling liquid
county -- can-- candies.
[ Laughter ]
-Man, I'm so tired
of these recalls.
Man, I constantly have to check
my fridge and check my freezer.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you saying?
-Anytime I want
to get some precut squash.
-Costco shoppers, check the
fridge, check the freezer.
Precut butternut squash is now
under recall
because of possible E. coli.
-Oh, my goodness.
This is unbelievable.
Look, I'm sure there's something
that you can eat. I'm sure.
-What do I even have left,
Jimmy?
I mean, some Kraft singles
American cheese slices?
-That sounds good.
I mean, I'm sure there won't be
any more recall alerts
for your family "tonalt."
-Another recall alert
for your family "tonalt.'
Kraft Heinz is recalling
some Kraft
singles American cheese slices.
-I'm done. I'm done.
-Tariq Trotter, everyone.
Tariq Trotter, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tonalt. We have
a good "Tonalt Show."
-Tonalt.
-Hey, guys,
I heard about a man in the U.K.
who said that he found
a fried screw in his KFC fries.
It turns out it was
from a chicken
that had a hip replacement.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, before we move on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
-♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
-Sun-Maid Raisins...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Cheez-Its...
The Home Depot...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gorilla Glue...
California Closets...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Subway...
And finally, Cocoa Puffs...
That's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots!
♪♪
Thank you very much.
Welcome to the show, everybody.
I just want to send our love
to everyone affected
by the attacks in Israel
over the weekend.
By now, we've all seen
the terrible images coming out
of there, and our hearts go out
to everyone who's been impacted.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
We have a great show tonight.
They are Tony-nominated actors
starring in the big new Broadway
show "Gutenberg! The Musical."
Josh Gad and Andrew Rannells
are here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-The best.
-The dynamic duo.
-Come on.
Josh Gad, Andrew Rannells.
Plus, he is currently on tour,
and his latest comedy special,
"Nate Bargatze: Hello World,"
it's my favorite
special I've seen in 10 years.
It is perfect special.
It is unbelievable.
If you haven't seen it,
just do it right now.
You can tune out of
"The Tonight Show."
Just flip over to watch it.
I think it's on Amazon.
He's unbelievable.
And gosh, he's been
a great friend of the show here
since the "Late Night" days.
-Yeah.
-Nate Bargatze is joining us
tonight.
He's one of my favorites.
He is crushing it.
Speaking of great stand-up,
we have great stand-up
from Ian Lara,
by the way, coming back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Love this dude as well.
Guys, stick around.
We'll be right back with
Josh Gad and Andrew Rannells
here on "The Tonight Show."